the difference is your point you're  doing point of sale versus point of sale  okay if Microsoft didn't have other  avenues to get you to coming off field  then I would tell you move the date  they have complete Divas  you got a 30 million head start on  whatever uh uh um Zelda is selling you  have a 30 million Head Start as far as  these engagement Nintendo's user bases  here's the thing you're looking at it  runs over Mario  you're looking at it from you're looking  at it from a sales Point standpoint I'm  looking at it from both of these are  massive games and we can only play one  right you can only play one no but but  King addicts defense you're acting like  everyone got chinchilla disposable  income to just do both at the same time  that's it make a decision that's that's  it I have faith in the 30 million  stronger since our Game Pass okay